hey youtubers is charlie and ben
wheatley the director who's doing the
first two episodes of Doctor Who series
8 just did a big interview where he said
that the new Doctor Who is going to be
much more like classic Doctor Who by
which he means dark and amazing I
literally just got done spending all
last night thinking about how Walking
Dead is gonna be super dark this year
and now that Doctor Who's gonna be super
dark this year I can't stop thinking
about the TARDIS being inside the prison
doctor who has done some zombie stories
by the way so I thought it'd be fun to
talk about the five big takeaways from
his interview I know I also said that
I'd be talking about some things we
learn from the set of series 8 there's a
big rumor about a possible cameo from a
certain other doctor if you're finding
me for the first time I always pick my
favorite comments to include in my Q&A
videos too I'll be doing one of those
later this week be sure to subscribe to
get it don't you just feel like everyone
is gonna rush to Netflix to watch
classic Doctor Who now so here are the
five big takeaways from Ben Wheatley's
interview number 5 think Tom Baker's run
the tone of his run is specifically
mentioned in the season 15 finale
invasion a time when Baker left his
companion Leela behind on Gallifrey that
was also one of the rare moments when he
turned to camera and addressed the
audience directly number 4 Capaldi is a
scholar of Doctor Who maybe not a degree
scholar but definitely a connoisseur as
opposed to Matt Smith who came to the
role with a completely fresh perspective
Capaldi has been watching Doctor Who
since he was a little boy he even got to
go on set and meet the third doctor
during his run he's an amazing actor so
he won't be copying any of the classic
doctors but I take his pre-existing
knowledge of the series to mean that
we'll see a lot of familiar traits so if
you do see a little bit of your favorite
classic doctors in its performance its
completely intentional number three
Wheatley has been mostly known for doing
science fiction horror stories right now
he's actually working on JG Ballard
high-rise to be specific what does it
tell you when the inaugural series 8
director is really big in the horror
genre it means that we're gonna get some
really awesome 70s looking horror sci-fi
Doctor Who episodes number 2 Capaldi is
still developing his doctor character
the filming of each episode happens
fairly quickly so it doesn't leave a lot
of time beforehand to completely develop
his new persona so we'll be seeing that
happen over the course of series 8 it's
always a lot of fun to watch how
different doctors have changed over the
course of their runs David Tennant and
Matt Smith just kept getting angrier and
angrier so I can't wait to watch Capaldi
blode maybe not literally though and the
number one big takeaway Capaldi is going
to be the darkest doctor we have ever
seen all the valued serious will enjoy
this even though I don't think the
Capaldi is the value whatever his
performance ends up looking like he will
essentially be the darkest scariest
version of the doctor we've ever seen
that by itself sounds so exciting to me
that I think even the most loyal classic
who fans are gonna really enjoy modern
who at least series eight and based on
the idea of a really scary Doctor Who
let me know in the comments what kind of
stories do you want to see think classic
sci-fi horror remember I'll be including
my favorite comments in my next Q&A
video now let's talk about that big
rumor we heard from the set of series 8
careful for spoilers if you don't want
to know anything it was said that there
was some dialogue between Capaldi and
Jenna Louise Coleman that implied Matt
Smith's doctor had made a phone call to
himself in the future to Capaldi's
doctor in theory it's meant to serve as
an epilogue for Matt Smith like one
final goodbye he doesn't appear on
screen so if it is true it would only be
a voiceover cameo it would make sense
given the amount of time Matt Smith
spent talking to handles about fixing
that phone during the Christmas special
if there's anything that I think Steven
Moffat does really well it's paying off
minor story points in really big ways
for instance River Song was originally
just a guest character until Moffat
magicked her into the character that we
know now let me know what you think
about the idea of a Matt Smith voiceover
during the series 8 premiere so my next
Doctor Who video will be that Q&A video
be sure to subscribe to get it
Walking Dead is also coming back this
weekend so much horror happening this
year it's gonna be really exciting right
now click here for my top 10 big
questions for Walking Dead this year and
click here for all my Doctor Who series
8 predictions thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you